it's very dangerous chuck because a lot
of what you're seeing
as attacks on me quite frankly are
attacks on science
so if you are trying to get at me
you're really attacking not only dr
anthony fauci you're attacking science
do you believe this starting to crack
the almighty faction makes it clear
criticize me you're criticizing science
really
what if a doctor scientists criticize
you do they not like science their own
profession
with more on this taking dr anthony
fauci's side
is voucher apologist jesse watts uh he
is a co-host of the five hosted
waters world on saturdays at eight and
author of the upcoming book comes out on
july 6th
how i saved the world so jesse yes
uh i did not know when he said this i
was on a shoot yesterday did you guys
tackle this on the five
we're going to tackle it tonight on the
phone so it came out after it did
so i mean your thoughts you're as
outraged and
he's the most overrated guy i've seen in
my life so
when you attack a liberal this is what
they do they say oh
you're attacking women you're attacking
me because i'm black
you're you're you're attacking the media
so they try to then assume this grand
identity
you're attacking science no we're not
even attacking
science we're we're criticizing you dr
fauci and he should be able to take the
heat
i don't know if chuck todd followed up
and said well dr fauci critics would say
that you did have it wrong on mass you
did have it wrong on how much danger
this pandemic would be
you did have it wrong to marginalize the
wuhan lab leak
you did have it wrong saying surfaces
are a place you can catch the virus you
did have it wrong when it said
you can catch it outside so i don't know
did he i it's
more than likely if he had followed up
like that it would be in the news but
i'll give him benefit of the doubt
he is so defensive he is also referring
to himself
in the third person if we listen to the
whole bite i'm not going to uh bore you
with we got the gist of it
he actually refers to himself if you
insult dr fauci excuse me
aren't you dr fauci well as someone that
likes to refer to himself in the third
person i'm not going to attack him for
that brian but
on part you're right he's as if you're
not on it
was looking to find out that's right
that's right and so but yeah he was
wrong on the lockdowns remember he
stuffed everybody inside when outside it
wasn't spreading
and we got it all wrong so we're not
really criticizing
science we're just saying listen you got
it wrong
what a half dozen times let's let's
let's get it together and get it right
so it doesn't happen again so
since we are not scientists we could
have been it's all who you know in that
business
dr peter mccullough is his cardiologist
internist and epidemiologist and he was
on lower last night
so your witness cut 13. well laura as a
practicing doctor and as a editor of two
major journals
i can tell you you know we hear from
lawyers
that no person is above the law and in
medicine
no doctor is above peer review and what
americans really
deserve to see over the last year is a
team of doctors preferably doctors who
actually knew how to treat
patients with covet 19 knew how to
rapidly interpret their literature
and come up with the correct differences
you know the science changed over time
and every time there was a definitive
statement within a few days or a few
weeks
there were new data coming out was
particularly with respect to treatment
listen we notice that as civilians i
think by the time
his book comes out november 3rd i know
it's all about july 6th with you
but as by the time his book comes out on
november 3rd i think he's going to be
totally disgraced i did too before
unlike cuomo he got it right after
he's going to get it before i do too and
that advance whatever he got i i hope it
wasn't more than what i got
for how i saved the world because that's
a disgrace is it a very similar book
yeah well mine's longer mine's 300 pages
he's only 80.
yeah i mean doctor schmokter but you're
right so
it wasn't just he was following the
science and the science developed
he was getting emails from scientific
leadership
saying it looks like the sequence never
mutated it looks like this was
manipulated and then he got on a
conference call with these scientists
they did a 180 and put out a paper and
says no no no
it came from an animal so he was
actually it was a scientific
conspiracy to then block scientific
research into the truth
all right i got to bring into something
else that's driving me nuts what i have
not been able to focus on
and that is i do fear uh joe joe biden's
foreign policy instincts and track
record
there's two things i worry about this
climate change agenda that's destroying
our energy our fossil fuel
which has been literally the engine of
our economy
this hydra the the uh fracking that has
allowed us to
to ship and use natural gas and of
course the oil
the drilling that's been taking place
he's getting rid of all of it page six
of the wall street journal today
not only is china not doing that they
say they're more moving away from
whatever they agree to on the paris
climate change they said
their focus is going to be on reviving
their economy
that's what our focus should be this is
president biden
saying to an audience in england what
he's
joined chiefs of staff are telling him
cut
[Music]
will warm it to three more than 1.5
degrees celsius
made the global global transition to
clean energy technology
you know when i'm over in the tank and
depending on when i first
elected the vice president president
obama
the military stands down let us hold the
greatest third station america
based physical threats this is not a
joke
you know what the church holds the
greatest threat facing america
i'd fire them all i would say listen is
that true do you guys
okay you're all gone i don't believe in
uniform i don't believe that
you told him that i think he made it up
he better i think he made it up that
would be actually the good side of this
story and i thought the
biggest threat was white supremacy right
wasn't that the biggest threat
and then last year was russia right and
then it was china
so like every other week it's a
different threat so
he instead of after the first hack this
is the message vladimir putin is sending
us and he's representing us after the
first hack
they were so scared about uh retribution
they hit us again
from the same country this time first
they got our uh our oil and gas
then they got our meat right right then
they said you know human rights is going
to come up navalny's health matters to
us
know what they said his organization is
now illegal there's no sign he's ever
going to get out they also arrested two
more dissidents in the meantime
these are messages sent to joe biden to
make him uncomfortable this is a quote
from their foreign minister
in uh on the doorstep of their meeting
uh
in vienna in a few days this is a
disaster
joe biden has to defend big beef in the
united states big beef and big oil
it's barbecue season brian we need to be
able to barbecue this beef
i would if i were the president right
before i sat down with vladimir putin
i'd have the defense department launch a
cyber attack on rosneft
the big oil company right there so he
finds out during the meeting
that the biggest oil company in russia
just got hacked and then afterwards i'd
say
we're gonna now re-up on all the
military package to ukraine
big satellite imagery shipment i i'd
lock in with all the tactical armaments
because they have snipers in the east
that are crushing the ukrainians and and
that's what i do i'd sandwich putin
with those two deals and i'd i'd force
him
to say next attack from russian
soil on america i'm holding the kremlin
personally responsible all right
am i overstating when i say kamala
harris has a disastrous two-day trip
i think that's about right i mean but
did you have it
with the issue what were your
expectations though brian i mean did you
really think she was going down there to
solve problems
she's buying time she doesn't want to go
to the border she doesn't want
photographs of her with border agents
at a wall praising border patrol agents
she wants to run for president one day
that'll just be an ad against her by
someone like aoc that can say
you know she's tough on immigrants she's
mean she's nasty she's pro border patrol
she doesn't want those images out there
so she's doing she's tap dancing
and avoiding the problem all right 180
000.
do you know what that number is that's
that's who i've crossed the 20 or right
173 the month before the problem is the
the the problem's getting worse in real
time it's not like how did you handle
that when you first kicked off and all
those kids were coming across dropped
over a wall
it's actually still happening what did
we open up to it this week on monday a
five-year-old walking around
by herself in front of the wall and then
you see a border agent grabbing him one
of these images
would have been the image we never
forgot about trump ingrained in our
minds in our psyche forever
so she's got an unfolding problem and i
just see henry cuellar today
called on biden and harris
to let the local people let the let the
local residents understand that you care
and come down to the border
corriere i don't need to tell you a
democrat i think that
i think they're going to have a hard
time outrunning this problem
well you know it gets really hot in the
summer so this migration pattern's
naturally going to die down
so they'll just pat themselves on the
back and claim that they fixed it but
it's just going to be just as bad next
year because they're not changing any of
the policies i think they're going to
get rocked in the midterms immigration
is a hot button issue
you think it's going to be a race i
think it's a harbinger of things to come
people are upset about it especially
people in texas they're trying to turn
texas blue brian
that's what they're trying to do right
but it's going the other way right now
and here's the other thing
but but politically right now it's going
the other way but if you get hundreds of
thousands of illegal immigrants pouring
into texas
and it's a lot of women you know they
have babies they're going to
if they get amnesty if they get asylum
they're going to vote democrat
first year generation immigrants always
vote democrat that's the game
they're going to suffer early short-term
consequences but long-term if they turn
texas blue
forget about it you'll never have
another republican president i went to
brian kilmeade i want you to do me a
favor i want you to click to subscribe
to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great
news bites any great interviews coming
your way on fox you can get it all here
on youtube so subscribe right now